música
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia a propósito del inédito bloqueo
del canal de suez en egipto por el
encallamiento del enorme buque
portacontenedores ever given
recordaremos en esta crónica los 150
años de pasado de esta vía marítima que
une a oriente y occidente desde la época
de los faraones los antiguos egipcios
soñaban unir el mar mediterráneo con el
mar rojo por entre los cauces del río
nilo uno de quienes ejecutó sin éxito
parte de la empresa fue ramsés segundo
mil doscientos años antes de cristo
quien sí consiguió una conexión
funcional en el antiguo egipto fue darío
primero rey de los persas setecientos
años después ya en el siglo 19 y
conociendo el potencial de bisagra de la
península del sinaí egipto en su calidad
de estado administrado por el imperio
otomano puso en marcha en 1859 la
construcción del canal de suez contra su
voluntad
decenas de miles de campesinos egipcios
fueron convocados en las obras de
excavación
por el empresario francés ferdinand de
lesseps el clima inhóspito y las
condiciones mal sanas de la titánica
obra de ingeniería cobraron la vida de
20.000 personas de acuerdo con los
cálculos más optimistas
la excavación avanzaba lenta porque el
trabajo se hacía a mano pero la
introducción de maquinaria pesada para
dragar el suelo aceleró el proceso en
total
el canal se construyó en 10 años luego
de haberse inaugurado en 1869 el canal
de suez atrajo el interés británico pero
en 1882 el imperio británico ocupó del
todo egipto en su campaña colonizadora
por áfrica y se hizo al atajo marítimo
para los viajes entre su mayor colonia
la india británica y londres disuelto el
imperio otomano acabada la primera
guerra mundial egipto se declaró como
estado soberano monárquico en 1922 pero
su total independencia de los británicos
la obtuvo en 1936 así quedó constatado
en el tratado anglo egipcio documento
que también incluyó la cláusula
que adjudicaba el control del canal de
suez a los ingleses entre 1952 y 1953
una sublevación del movimiento de
oficiales libres en el cairo derrocó la
monarquía egipcia e instauró la
república entre los oficiales golpistas
se encontraba gamal abdel nasser el
futuro presidente que a la posteridad
sería recordado como el impulsor del
panarabismo y el padre del egipto
moderno y no lo habría sido de no haber
nacionalizado el canal de suez en 1956 y
así haber presionado al banco mundial
para que le prestara el dinero con el
cual construir la presa de asuán
el megaproyecto con el cual se
detuvieron las históricas inundaciones
del río nilo y favoreció la economía de
millones de campesinos ribereños la
movida política económica y militar de
nasser agarró por sorpresa a los
británicos y sus accionistas del canal
los franceses
en contrapartida francia e inglaterra
con el espaldarazo de israel invadieron
militarmente la península del sinaí en
lo que se conoce como la
crisis de suez una tensión internacional
que se saldó con el retiro de dichas
tropas luego de que eeuu la unión
soviética y las naciones unidas-
intervinieran a favor de nacer no
obstante en junio de 1967 con la guerra
de los seis días que dio una aplastante
victoria a israel sobre egipto siria y
jordania la península del sinaí quedó en
manos de israelíes y el canal cerró sus
esclusas en 1970
gamal abdel nasser murió inesperadamente
por un ataque cardíaco a sus 52 años el
país quedó sumido en un duelo y en el
gran interrogante sobre el destino del
canal de suez el vice presidente anuar
el sadat lo sucedió y adelantó una serie
de intrigas de guerra con su enemigo
israel entre 1970 y 1973
sadat alterno sus iniciativas de paz con
la amenaza de sacrificar un millón de
soldados egipcios con tal de recuperar
el sinaí este fue el antecedente para la
guerra del yom kippur
que estalló con el ataque sorpresa de
egipto y siria contra las bases
militares de israel en los territorios
capturados del sinaí y los altos del
golán la guerra del yom kipur que debe
su nombre al ataque en el día más
sagrado del judaísmo quedó en tablas
pero le demostró a israel que su
permanencia en el sinaí no sería posible
dada la obstinación egipcia por
recuperarlo composiciones ganadas en el
sinaí egipto pudo reabrir el canal de
suez en 1975 y tres años más tarde en
1978 la nación árabe logró controlar
nuevamente la totalidad de la península
tras los acuerdos de camp david entre
anuar el sadat y menahem béguin firmados
en la residencia de jimmy carter- que
fungía como presidente de eeuu después
de su reapertura en 1975 el canal de
suez se mantuvo con normalidad hasta que
en 2015 el actual presidente abdel
fattah al cis y invirtió más de 8 mil
millones de dólares para expandirlo y
reactivar así una economía en crisis
tras 150 años de haberse construido el
canal jamás había sido testigo de un
encallamiento del calado del buque error
given la mega nave de 200 mil toneladas
que realizaba su viaje desde el puerto
chino de yantián hasta el puerto de
rotterdam en países bajos
taponó el paso por donde discurre más
del 10% del comercio mundial y entre el
7 y 9 por ciento del petróleo del
planeta una ruta que evita a los enormes
cargueros la penosa travesía de navegar
5 mil kilómetros alrededor de áfrica
así concluimos soy andrés suárez
jaramillo gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]